so why does Dark Knight get DC Comics
but the Green Lantern just gets DC also
DC billions of years ago a race of
immortal
narration pieced together from all of
Marlon Brando's lifetime recorded audio
Megamind this heads-up display contains
no useful features whatsoever Aden sewer
didn't think that pushing a few rocks in
front of parallax was necessary because
you know what are the chances he'll my
boy sure made quick work of that jello
mold prison also three people's souls is
all it takes to get free of willpower
Ghost Rider alien bad guy why does a
green lantern that can fly through space
on his own the most powerful of all
Green Lanterns mind you need a pink
spaceship in sprint powerful mystical
ring doesn't know there's a huge ball of
fear approaching to the last moment
she's now he's getting in another
spaceship we definitely wouldn't respect
Hal Jordan if he didn't wake up next to
some naked babe let's get these pants
off and fly some plane
man how Jordan is such a devil-may-care
rebel he's like the Van Wilder of test
pilots on your way to where you're
already there right well this isn't like
Iron Man at all and you move the
contract at this company and half the
state used it only in movies does an
awesome invention get can because some
asshole decided to not only break the
rules but to do something no pilot would
have done under any circumstance you're
fired
dude at least take the severance package
why did parallax let up and Sewer get
away in this tiny ship was the devourer
of worlds not fast enough to catch it or
is it just that the plot demanded it
nobody sees this flying green ball
anywhere in the city bright sunny day
becomes dark inky night in just a couple
of seconds nobody saw the spaceship
crash and then it takes the military all
damn day to get there how much is the
same alien body that Hector later
touches but doesn't get infected with
the yellow fear goop and with great
responsibility comes great power wait
we're gone yeah the Sela copters are
clearly close enough to spot you already
as well as just follow you or shoot you
for witnessing proof of aliens that was
a great honor responsibility and with
great responsibility comes damn it this
guy looks like the devil and his name is
based on the word sinister the student
was destined to turn evil it only was
whoa it's paralyzed no his final words
were I'm badly wounded heading to the
nearest inhabited planet for the
selection process tell the Guardians its
parallax Carroll doesn't notice the huge
green ring on Houzz middle finger at any
time not that he would have known what
it meant but house ring fails to glow
when these dickheads show up
I guess we're supposed to be happy that
Hal just killed three guys wait so every
freaking car in this dive bar alley
parking area has an alarm system even
the fing tow truck also didn't Hal just
get slammed into the green truck and
nothing happened at all no one from
anywhere gives it about all the
commotion happening in the parking lot
astronauts must see people flying around
in green energy clouds all the time of
all the things to CG of king masks I
mean how much money did you really save
with this moon since time immemorial the
Green Lantern Corps served as the
keepers of peace order and justice
throughout the universe well they let
this movie get made so where were you on
that one dickheads and the greatest of
responsibilities and with great
responsibility son of a bitch Green is
the color of will how can green be the
color of both will and envy when how I
left the apartment the lanterns on the
table but when he returns it's gone this
girl on the end doesn't give it that
somebody just got thrown to the front of
the class by magic maybe get some sleep
son senator Hammond must have had Hector
when he was 13 years old
Hector's eyes don't glow yellow when
he's reading his father's money there
are 3,600 green lanterns but apparently
only 12 are needed on this mission to
kill parallax an immortal who has
destroyed two planets uh a net is what
they think will contain parallax we must
prepare to harness the power of our
enemy and fight fear with fear in other
words the only thing that fear has to
fear is fear itself
they do not let people land helicopters
this close to pedestrians even if you
have a little circle of red markers to
define a landing area this guy's here
ice
yeah my dad used to train in them I was
talking about your dress
so machine I guess this dude hector
takes the champagne from took a look at
Carol Ferris and said yeah I'd probably
do the same thing
salmon an alien body reason Hammonds dad
can apparently hear his sons
conversation from ten feet away at a
fairly loud party don't helicopters
usually cause large amounts of wind what
an odd way to try and disable a
helicopter when you have this
telekinesis thing wait did we get that
right it's telekinesis this time damn it
everyone in the helicopter should be
dead or severely injured when it crashes
through the screen
helicopter blades managed to crash
through this heavily populated party
without touching anyone Hey look it's
probably Hal Jordan this is really
related to the plot whatsoever but do we
need to know that somebody killed dr.
Wohlers family what's keeping dr. Waller
stuck to this glass trick you just took
out a whole squad of the toughest
lanterns with the brand-new lantern from
the young human species is a threat they
say unearthly say I'm only human we say
because we know we're afraid we do not
say that because of fear we say that
because we've colossal II something up
nobody who looks to the skies for a
living sees this huge monster
approaching earth possibly the saddest
villain death ever who cries for Hector
Hammond he didn't ask for this wasn't
driven by greed or power and now he dies
without redemption even Darth Vader got
Redemption Carroll fires earth missiles
into an intergalactic world eating fear
monster and it actually works
why does parallax decide to ignore
everyone else running around and focus
on this random lady who fell in the
street
in every car in this city has an alarm
how and parallax go through the asteroid
belt which is between Mars and Jupiter
now somehow they've managed to get to
the Sun ten seconds which is on the
other side where they came from a giant
fist is what knocks parallax into the
Sun almost nothing ever affected him the
whole movie and now a pink fist
Sinestro only shows up after has already
destroyed the parallax Sinestro cannot
Traynham
or cannot train dude you literally spent
like three minutes beating him up and
then Sinestro took over the train that
and so I found another just like himself
Ivan sir had nothing to do with the
selection process the ring did the work
plate someone decent directedness see
told you
host city is the fictional city that Hal
Jordan lives in in the comics so I want
to give the production credit for
attention to detail by having this
license plate here say Coast City except
that I have to take points right back
because cities don't have unique license
plates well except for Washington DC
also is house license plate a
Pennsylvania one from the 80s and 90s
Coast City is in California how do we
know this is the bedroom of a typical
little boy well there's an orgy of
evidence we've got sports cars sports
cars planes rockets dinosaurs more
sports and just for good measure a
million Rubik's cubes NFL Blitz hey boss
I got the props all set up for this
dudes office since he's a mad scientist
I put three computer screens on his desk
seriously you think it needs a four okay
you're the director pokemon sapphire
exactly how much did the set designer of
this film love the color orange this
much
I know right gosh
there goes HBO